Democrats who were looking forward to the
election of Hillary Clinton and
expecting that it would happen, have some
obstacles ahead of them in 2018 for
maintaining majorities in Congress. Now
with the election of Donald Trump, it
looks a little more forbidding for them.
The Senate seats that are up in 2018,
you've got ten Democratic senators
running for re-election in states that
were carried by Donald Trump. That's not
a good place to start off for the
Democratic Party. You have very few
Republican seats at risk.
It's the opposite of the situation this
year. And so the likelihood is that the
Republicans will gain seats. If the Trump
administration is seen as successful
and producing good results,
the Democrats might lose quite a few seats.
If the Trump administration is seen as
unsuccessful, Democrats might hold losses
down towards zero. So, we'll see about
that. In the House of Representatives:
remember, Mitt Romney carried a majority
of House seats—226. Donald Trump carried
more than that. That's going to make it
tough for the Democrats to gain the
seats they need for a majority in the house.